last night was kind of silent we haven't
been bombed by russian troops but three
last days we were bombed
mostly by
the bombardment was by
rockets with a cluster a cluster
missiles
which
are illegal actually but they use it
against
uh civilians and the main aim of this
type of bombs are really
people i mean alive force
so
this last night we see that they're
regrouping and uh
get the reinforcement by their side from
the crimea uh right now mclife is
surrounded by russian troops let's say
two quarters uh three quarters
from her son direction from uh east
south and from uh east north from
kropovnitsky direction
and when you're talking about the
bombardment and
you're basically saying that they're
targeting civilians are you
right
174 buildings were
destroyed partially or totally while
these uh recent five days of
bombardments
we had one of uh
city hospitals where
were destroyed partially mostly
uh windows and
the roof but we repaired it and now it's
working in a
normal
way
so with russian troops surrounding
two-thirds as you were describing there
of your city
what are the residents doing to protect
themselves
uh
we evacuate uh people uh to a desert
direction this is the only way for us to
evocate people and to get food uh the
products uh and uh the everyone who can
hold the weapon and to
everyone who is ready to protect
uh the city and the
our country they are armed and they are
staying
uh
for the defense and they are ready to
stay till the last ammo
and can people still get out mr sankovic
right people can still get out we use we
use our buses that we that we're in for
for transportation in the city we use
these buses to send people to odessa and
then to
poland world to
western
ukraine
you're a long way relatively speaking
within ukraine from the border with
russia reports uh coming to us here are
the russian troops are running out of
food and fuel is that right is that what
you can see with the troops that are
surrounding your city
that's what i just said in the beginning
they are regrouping they fall back they
felt back a little uh just to regroup
and to get some food some
fuel uh and uh i think they will start
attack uh in the nearest day so for sure
they have problems with the food and
food because they uh uh
in the villages near the city so they
don't come closer to nikolai more than
30 kilometers so our artillery can hit
them and they uh
they go to the nearest villages and
make make robbery
in the shops so they
they steal food they still
feel from the gas stations in the
villages
when you hear vladimir putin accusing
ukraine of potentially um
using chemical weapons
what does that make you what does that
make you think about what might happen
uh first of all everything that vladimir
putin says it's a liar
so he
when he says something that means
that uh that he will do something and he
will he's trying to
uh to cover his liar and his actions by
this life so um first of all uh they
kill civilians mostly civilians they
their bombardment ruin our cities you
see the catastrophe that happens now in
mariupol they don't give a green
corridor for people who want to leave
the city people inside the city don't
they don't have water electricity gas
anything so they are dying there and you
i'm not sure if you've seen that those
videos where people are burying in the
you know in the trent in trenches i mean
civilians from the marupo and uh they
what they do they do the same thing that
what that
germans did in world war ii
so uh everything that he says he's
trying only to cover his next action so
i won't be surprised if he he'll use
the chemical weapons um on us
and mr sanchez when you look at mario
paul which you're describing there do
you think that is the fate of your city
uh i hope no uh
our our people uh really to defend uh
our city the troops are in front of the
city we are ready to fight you know that
what we see now when we hit russian
uh
russian techniques i mean tanks and
everything there are people just running
out they don't uh they don't ready to
protect themselves they are just running
because they understand they that they
are occupants and we
never uh
invaded russia but they do it now and
they understand that uh almost everyone
who were captured by our troops they say
that they didn't know where they go that
they did
in a training but we understand that
they just have a you know order to say
that when they are captured
well mr sankovich really appreciate you
talking to us and i wish you and your
people well thank you thank you